qu'est ce que c'est la richesse pour
vous est ce que c'est une histoire
d'argent de rencontres de voyages ou
d'expérience
personnellement j'ai une grande
expérience dans le voyage et ce dont je
vais vous parler aujourd'hui
mais avant tout laissez moi vous
expliquer l'histoire d'un petit garçon
qui est timide et qui n'osaient pas
aller vers les autres à tel point qu'il
est timide qui l'avait même besoin de sa
maman pour dormir quelque part et ce
petit garçon eh ben c'est moi et à 12
ans
mes parents m'ont pris pour voyager en
thaïlande une vraie aventure nous avons
voyagé comme des backpackers pour ceux
qui ne savent pas c'est un voyage en sac
à dos nous avons presque parcouru la
totalité de la thaïlande et la plupart
du temps nous avons rencontré des locaux
la thaïlande nous donner beaucoup alors
qu'elles n'avaient quasi presque rien
pour moi ça a été mon premier déclic et
ce déclic s'est dit de me dire de faire
une promesse et cette promesse c'est de
me dire que à mes 18 ans je partirai
pour autour du monde mais après avoir
fait cette promesse j'ai fait
malheureusement une chute de quatre
mètres en moto en thaïlande et je me
suis retrouvé pendant deux semaines à
l'hôpital
et malheureusement après avoir fait
cette chute j'ai quand même voulu tenir
cette promesse de me dire que à 18 ans
je partirai pour un tour du monde
à 15 ans je suis parti en tant que
bénévole en afrique au bénin et j'étais
sélectionnée est préparé pour vivre
cette expérience
en tant que bénévole j'étais là pour
replanter des arbres sur 7 hectares et
des enfants dans des écoles mais on
vivait dans des conditions assez
spécifique on avait pas de télévision
une liste de contacts avec notre famille
est ni de réseaux sociaux en fait on est
c'est en immersion totale
la plupart du temps ont pu faire que les
autochtones machette à la main on avait
nos habits dans des bassines d'eau
froide on dormait à même le sol on avait
des douches froides
et même que à certains moments j'avais
pas toujours assez à manger
à tel point que je voyais mes joues
creuses et m'écoutent sur le côté et
pour vous dire je me suis même fait pote
avec le cuistot au mans j'ai un petit
peu plus
mais je n'oublierai jamais le sourire de
ses enfants il était content pour tout
et n'importe quoi l'afrique m'a vraiment
permis de vivre le moment prison des
choses et j'ai compris ce que le terme
chance voulait signifier
une rencontre marquée salle de petit
enfant qui m'a dit toi leblanc qui a
nous montre je ne sais pas prendre le
temps et moi j'en ai pas et je sais
prendre le temps
après l'afrique je suis rentré chez moi
j'ai vu la taille de ma maison j'ai
ouvert le frigo j'ai vu toute la
nourriture j'ai pris une douche chaude
au final j'ai retrouvé le confort et je
me suis dit est-ce qu'on doit perdre les
choses pour comprendre la valeur
qu'elles ont
à 15 ans
j'ai reçu la plus grosse claque de toute
ma vie
mais à 15 ans je me sentais comme
incompris par rapport aux autres jeunes
de mon âge
on n'a pas toujours la chance de
comprendre ce que l'on a
et au final voilà que les années pas
j'arrive à mes 16 ans et je pars pour
faire le tour du mont blanc france
suisse italie à des alpinistes
à mes 17 ans je pars au canada offert
deux mois des changes et à mes 18 ans si
vous vous rappelez bien je me suis fait
une promesse à 12 ans celle de faire le
tour du monde
et de la j'organise une soirée j'invite
tous mes amis et je leur annonce que
c'est peut-être la dernière fois qu'ils
me verront au final je pars je pars je
savais où j'allais mais je sais pas où
cela me mènera l'inconnue totale de la
vie
et je pars en équateur où je traverse
toute l'amazonie jusqu'à des montagnes
plus ou que le mont blanc je passe par
le costa rica où j'étais bénévole de ses
bébés tortues et des jaguars je passe
par l'australie la nouvelle zélande en
fait une totalité de plein de pays
mais je n'oublierai jamais
les premiers jours de mon tour du monde
j'étais dans un bus taxis et je vois une
fille qui pleurait devant - elle avait
les matches se jouent et larmes qui
coulaient et je vais demander bien sûr
si tout allait bien et elle m'a dit tu
as de la chance je me suis dit pourquoi
elle m'a dit que à l'étude y cinq ans au
faire plaisir à sa famille et qu'elle ne
se connaissaient pas assez écoeurant
voyageant elle a appris à se connaître
et au final elle me dit que je ne veux
plus être avocate une qu'elle veut
travailler que les enfants
il ya le pleure parce qu'elle a cinq
années de sa vie à étudier quelque chose
qu'elle ne ferait pas
j'ai compris que la plupart des gens ne
se connaissent pas assez
épais en voyageant on apprend à se
connaître
moi ce que j'adore autour du monde c'est
de me retrouver autour d'une table de
discussion et de casser les schémas la
société parce qu'au final on retrouve
des personnes de tout âge de tout métier
de toute culture
et au final on s'en fout un peu de qui
tu es on veut juste passer un bon moment
et c'est là que mon nom de cette table
on parle de plein de choses
la discussion et tu as croit tellement
de choses sur la vie
comme quoi tout n'est pas pareil au tour
du monde et ce qui est incroyable c'est
que quand tu voyages tu voyages au pays
mais tu vois je suis en même temps à
travers les autres et ce qui m'a marqué
c'est l'ouverture d'esprit des voyageurs
et voilà que plusieurs expériences en
chaîne mais voilà en australie je
travaille à signer en tant que barman
est quand même plutôt bien ma vie 1500
dollars la semaine
et je me suis dit elle et où l'histoire
et j'ai pété un plomb j'ai pété un plan
de 10 en finale doit vite pour acheter
au tour en avion et je me suis dit allez
où l'expérience que tu peux retrouver
dans les films dans les bouquins et je
me suis lancé un challenge et ce
challenge c'est de me dire que je ferai
la nouvelle zélande en stop comme ça je
les prendrai plus de mon argent mais de
la personne qui allait s'arrêter devant
moi
et j'ai une anecdote
le troisième jour quand je faisais du
stop en nouvelle zélande j'étais sur un
petit trottoir
il a un mec qui arrive au loin d'un côté
il y avait des longs cheveux acolytes
plein dedans et il me demande de venir
travailler lui sur ce bateau ne
connaissons pas ce monsieur je pars à sa
rencontre pour discuter avec lui
j'apprends finalement il a perdu la
charge de ces enfants et en discutant
avec lui j'apprends que c'est très mal
personne et j'accepte et me voilà
finalement au maire rejoint sûr c'est
légal en train de pêcher du poisson
il a au bout d'un moment ce pêcheur
mehdi watchou vite ce qui veut dire fais
attention à tes pieds et là il me crie
chaque rouquin et à ce moment là il me
sort aucun d'un médecin quand sur le
bateau j'étais terrifiée mes yeux
écarquillés mon coeur battait 200 à
l'heure je savais pas quoi faire le
requin des dents - et slash jacques cela
qu il essaye de me mordre moi juste
vérifier je montre sur des palettes et
je vois le pêcheur qui a vu juste avec
moi avec le couteau et schlak et coupe
la tête du requin schlak j'ai du genre
du sang qui gicle sur la tête et juste à
ce moment là je rembobine à cassettes et
je me rappelle que cette histoire là
simplement démarrer asap le pousse au
bord d'une route
et voilà que plusieurs expériences
aventures s'enchaînent en nouvelle
zélande et dans d'autres pays et voilà
que ça fait deux ans et quelques mois
que je n'ai pas vu ma famille mon petit
frère grandir et je décide de rentrer
mais de prévenir personne
ma mère qui travaille dans un hôpital je
suis fait la surprise je me dise dans
l'ide un patient et pour elle c'était la
joie mais en même temps la peur la peur
de me retrouver ma dans un lit dans un
hôpital en pensant que je sois blessé ou
autre
mon petit frère j'étais dans son lycée
oui j'ai été voir le directeur et je lui
ai dit de l'appeler dans les bureaux et
je lui ai fait une surprise
et mon père simplement on travaille et
je le fais une surprise au final voilà
que quelques semaines passent je suis
chez moi je suis avec un ami on brandit
piscine et je dis tu sais j'ai compris
quelque chose en faisant ce tour du
monde
j'ai compris que je tousse qu'une
personne raid avoir au final maisons une
piscine une voiture mais j'ai compris
que après mon déclic après ma claque
après mon pit âge de plomb j'ai compris
que je vais acheter beaucoup de choses
de la vie
mais il ya quelque chose que tu ne
pourras jamais vraiment acheter
c'est l'expérience tu sais pourquoi
parce que tu dois la vivre
et pour répondre à ma question
qu'est ce que c'est pour vous la
richesse
ben pour moi sheth c'est de l'expérience
et de vivre le moment présent
il n'oublie pas vous avez tous qu'une
vie est passé dans votre vie celle ci
n'est qu'un voyage
[Applaudissements]